a man is a man and a woman is a woman
and there's no reason to qualify these
things at all i don't think
we should in any way validate this
gnostic delusion
of gender ideology but they're doing it
they're doing it everywhere in great
britain right now
i kid you not a group of hospitals is
instructing midwives and maternity
departments to use different terms
when treating transgender patients to be
more gender inclusive
meaning instead of breastfeeding you
you have to use the term chest feeding
instead of breast milk you have to use
the term
human milk okay
instead of breast milk you could also
say milk from the feeding mother or
parent that's another long one
very inhuman this kind of language
erases
women right it says no there's no such
thing as women we're all just kind of
generic people
and so anything that might distinguish
women from men we're going to
get rid of it but it's inhuman more
broadly
we shouldn't use this kind of thing we
shouldn't indulge it in any way
and conservatives to be polite want to
do that you want to say well
look i don't care if a man thinks he's a
woman and he
he wants to wear a dress in his own
private life who for be it for me who am
i to say
you are somebody you can have an opinion
on this
men should not dress like women and
behave like women
if they do it it should only be as part
of some very sort of outrageous costume
or something
it should be with the acknowledgement
that this is strange
out of the ordinary and not the way
things are supposed to be
conservatives need to get much more
serious about this sort of thing
we live in such a glib time that you
have the radical saying well there's no
rules to anything we can liberate
ourselves however we want
men can be women women can be men
there's chest milk and what whatever you
know
milk from the feeding parent and but
then on the other side of the glibness
you've got these conservatives
who are refusing to offer any other
vision they're saying yeah whatever you
want to do
as long as i don't have to pay for it as
long as it doesn't affect my bottom line
do whatever you want no
guys that is not a serious political
vision
when you when you offer a political
vision you have to be able to say this
is the way the world is
and some things are true and some things
are false and i'm going to stand up for
the things that are true
and i'm going to oppose the things that
are false if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you